Then the meme stream and then they later
kind of took a joyless turn.
Yeah,
yesterday on today.
Right now.
Yeah.
Well it's amazing.
So here's the strange thing.
So I kind of played,
let's say night on white horse.
And so the Guardian yesterday published
the
astounding,
really reprehensible article about your
boot know about the channel for
interview.
Um,
no,
they,
they've done some nice interviews about
my book.
Um,
so it'd been kind of all over the place
with me,
you know,
but the channel for people claim that
Kathy has been targeted with threats.
No,
I'm a torrent of online abuse by
Internet trolls.
It's like 50,000 trolls,
you know,
that's a lot of trolls.
You might start thinking maybe they're
not old trolls,
but in any case,
overwhelmed by Ms Dot logistic abuse and
threats and that they had called in a
security specialist to assess the level
of threat.
And so it was the beginning of the
attempt to twist the story around so
that the story became
Kathy Newman,
poor embattled channel four newscaster
was merely trying to do her job even
though she might've been a bit
provocative,
interviewed alt right hero,
Dr Jordan Peterson in an honest manner
to,
to expose his agenda,
posted the results to youtube,
and was immediately mobbed by his army
of Internet trolls.
Right?
So she went from.
So my sense is she went from a
journalist playing a variety of
complicated games to,
to,
to target of criticism online to heroin,
embattled heroin in the panoply of
martyrs to whom similar things have
happened in the past and what's terrible
about it.
So,
so.
And I inadvertently I would say
contributed to that because when the
Guardian story came out,
I read it and the story purported to be
about the threats that she had received.
But really the story because the story
opened with a description of me and the
description was,
let's call it far from flattery.
You know,
it was the same old thing.
Dr Peterson,
he's a provocateur.
He's has an army of trolls.
If anybody ever dares to challenge him,
let's say I know all they're doing is
honestly challenging.
The trolls come out and then they have
to fear for their lives and that was.
That was the story,
the threat,
the threats were just the pre requisite
for the story and then yeah,
like a dozen UK news media sources that
the newspapers in particular have picked
us up some even more critical of me than
that.
Some in a slightly more balanced
fashion,
but and see when the Guardian story
broke,
I tweeted something.
I said,
look,
if you're.
I've looked at the tweet or the youtube
comments and most of them were merely
criticism,
but if you're threatening her while
stop,
you know,
because we had an exchange of words,
which is what we're supposed to do.
I think this message to your front row
was one of the most liked tweet you ever
put out.
Yeah,
but here's the terrible thing about it.
You know,
what happened was that the fact that I
tweeted that was instantly used as
validation for the claim that there were
threats and that was just,
yeah,
that's what happened.
And See,
it's weird because when I wrote that I
thought was part of me that thought
that thought that that might happen.
There was a little warning bell that
went off that said,
look,
you know,
there's no evidence that these threats
are credible and if you respond by by
asking people to back off,
you're also implying that there are
people who,
who should back off that this is real.
And I thought,
no,
I'm going to do it anyways because she
has been targeted.
She has been subject to a very large
number of very vitriolic comments and
maybe that's enough.
And so you know,
it's okay to come out and say that's
enough.
But the thing is it wasn't okay because
as soon as I did it,
then the fact that I did it was used as
proof that all of these claims were
valid and that that just floored me.
Like I was very
distraught,
I think is the right word about that
this morning because I didn't,
I didn't see that coming.
But were there threats against her?
Have you seen them?
Defined threat?
There's no threats that were sufficient
to get the police involved.